LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Googleplex.
This is an incredible
place with lots
of great stuff being
worked on every single day.
Before I worked here,
I always wondered
what would it would like
to come to the Googleplex,
meet up with a Googler, and
have coffee with them, just chat
about what they do, how they
do it, and why they do it.
And today we're going
to do exactly that.
AUTOMATED VOICE:
Here's the message.
Would you like to
join me for coffee?
ANDREW BRENNER: Reply.
AUTOMATED VOICE:
Say your message.
ANDREW BRENNER: Sure.
I'll pick you up.
AUTOMATED VOICE:
Sending message.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I'm getting my coffee
to go today with a Googler who
always seems to be on the go.
Andrew Brenner is from the
Android automotive team,
and they work on the
coolest possible things.
And it looks like he's taking
me there in his cool car.
Should we take a look?
Nice wheels, man!
ANDREW BRENNER: Hop in.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
What is this?
ANDREW BRENNER:
This is Android Auto
running in this Hyundai Sonata.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
What does it do?
ANDREW BRENNER:
Let's go get coffee.
Press it right on the screen.
We'll navigate using
Google Maps and get coffee.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sweet!
ANDREW BRENNER: So this is
my Google Now cards, but only
the ones that are
appropriate when I'm driving.
So since I know that
we have an appointment
to get coffee right now,
I'm going to press this,
and we're going to
launch Google Maps.
And now Google Maps
is navigating me
on my car screen using the
car's GPS, which is much more
accurate, as we
go and get coffee.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's even
got traffic conditions.
I can see the yellow there.
Sweet.
ANDREW BRENNER: Absolutely.
So it will tell us the estimate
of the time that we're going.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
This is allowing
you to keep your
eyes on the road
and keep your hands on
the steering wheel, right?
ANDREW BRENNER: Absolutely.
And Google Maps is updating
me where to go next,
and it's the same voice
instructions and interface
that you're really kind of
used to from your phone.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
Now, this isn't a device
that's within the car itself.
This is your phone being
extended into the car,
and it's the car [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW BRENNER: That's right.
So we have some software
that's on the car itself
to let the car talk with
the phone in this new way.
And so with the
software, the phone's
able to broadcast through
a wire, a USB cable.
So we also have other apps,
too, like Google Music.
So here's Play Music.
And I can hit Play, and
I'm now playing music
through my car speakers
while I'm navigating.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
ANDREW BRENNER: So you'll see
when the next turn comes up,
it will show that on the screen.
If you go back to navigation
and do all sorts of cool things
there.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Outstanding.
Nice.
ANDREW BRENNER: Now, I have some
other tricks we have here, too.
You want to see some of those?
Bring them on.
We've not only gotten
the GPS from the car,
but we also have some
of the car buttons.
So there's one
button in particular
we thought was
really interesting,
which is the steering
wheel button.
When I press the steering
wheel button and speak into it,
I can talk to Google, and we
can ask Google lots of things,
such as, how tall
is Stephen Colbert?
AUTOMATED VOICE: Stephen Colbert
is 5 feet 10 and 1/2 inches,
or 1.79 meters tall.
ANDREW BRENNER: Pretty
accurate, right?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
It's from Google.
It's got to be right.
ANDREW BRENNER: So
there's some other things
we can ask it, too, like, what's
my next appointment, right?
Let's try that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sure.
ANDREW BRENNER: What's
my next appointment?
AUTOMATED VOICE: Your
next calendar entry
is today at 4:00 PM.
The title is Android
Automotive Monthly Update.
ANDREW BRENNER: And I can
do other things, as well.
I can also control
Google applications.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Now, one of things
I remember hearing was that,
before you joined Google,
you'd actually, like,
hacked up your own car
and put a tablet into it.
ANDREW BRENNER: I did.
Long before I got
this role at Google,
I was really interested in this.
So I hated the navigation
system that was in my car.
So I went one day, and I ripped
it out, and I took a Nexus 7,
and it fit in the opening.
So I basically put it in there.
And then I spent a lot
of time figuring out
how to do programming
to make the Nexus 7
act as if it was a car stereo.
LAURENCE MORONEY: What kind
of weird, funny, crazy stuff
happened while you were working?
ANDREW BRENNER: When we
first got something working
in a car, the first time,
we need to kind of test
our builds everyday
to see the stability,
to see if they worked,
see the integration
with Google Apps and services.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So you've got
to drive somewhere important?
ANDREW BRENNER: I had to
drive somewhere important, so
what better thing to do than to
drive to get donuts every day?
So I would pile into the
car with the engineers,
and some of them would
have their laptops open,
and we would say, navigate
to the donut shop using
Voice and other methods, such
as putting it in Google Now.
And we would go to the
donut shop every day
and see what the quality
was in the build.
And, of course, we
would have to get, like,
about three dozen
donuts on the way back,
and the person in the
donut shop thought
we were absolutely nuts,
because every day there
would be these engineers showing
up with their laptops open,
and we would order lots
of donuts and leave.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So what
happened to all the donuts?
ANDREW BRENNER: They
got ingested and put
into the product with love.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's why
it's such a sweet product.
ANDREW BRENNER: That's right.
Absolutely.
LAURENCE MORONEY: This isn't
a closed system in a car
that only the car manufacturers
could put apps on it.
It's Android, so developers,
can put apps on it themselves.
ANDREW BRENNER: Yeah.
So what we want to
do is to really bring
developers along for the ride
with this whole thing, right--
LAURENCE MORONEY:
No pun intended.
ANDREW BRENNER: No pun
intended, of course.
So we looked at the use cases
that people do in their car.
Like, what do people
actually do in their car?
And the two things
that highlighted to us
that third party developers
would be looking at right away
are playing music and
being able to get messages
from third party applications.
So you can use APIs
that we're releasing
to be able to create
an application that
can send messages that come
through onto a car screen.
It reads the message
to you just like we
showed at the beginning
of this video,
and then you can
reply via voice.
And that gets sent back to the
person using the app that's
on the phone that the
developer creates.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now, if I'm a
developer, and I created that,
how do I get that in
the hands of users?
ANDREW BRENNER: So we're
going to have a process that's
coming soon with
the Play Store where
you can submit your app to
the Play Store and publish it,
and it will be able to
be on people's phones,
and they just download it
through the normal Play Store
channel.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So an app for my car
is just like any other app.
It's like downloading
Flappy Bird.
It's like downloading whatever.
ANDREW BRENNER: That's right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And it's
going to work on my car.
ANDREW BRENNER: It's
just on your phone.
But, of course, we're
not enabling Flappy Birds
right now.
Maybe when you're
parked in the future,
but no games right now
when you're driving.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sure.
Sure.
But it's easy as that to get
an app, though, into my car.
ANDREW BRENNER: Absolutely.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's awesome.
ANDREW BRENNER: Because
it's actually on your phone.
Think of this as a screen
that's attached to your phone,
as if you attached your
laptop to an external monitor.
That's basically what
you're doing here.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now,
obviously the car screen
is a little bit different,
and not everybody has access
to a car so they could
start developing.
As a dev, I need
to be testing it.
Is there some kind of
emulation environment?
ANDREW BRENNER: On the site
that we'll have a link to,
there's also an SDK emulator,
as well, for both messaging
and for media.
So you don't need to buy a
car in order to test your app,
and you're able to test and
see how the app will run.
And make sure you follow our
Android UX guidelines for Auto
before you submit
your app to us.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
ANDREW BRENNER: We want to
make sure everything is set up
in a good way for
users in the car
so there's nothing unexpected
when they should be driving.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So I'm a developer.
I can download this SDK today.
I could read the
guidelines today.
I can get the emulator today.
There's no reason why
I can't extend my app
to make it a fabulous
car app, as well as
a phone app or a wear app
or that kind of thing.
So why shouldn't I
just get started?
I think it's just
the greatest thing.
ANDREW BRENNER: Yeah.
I think you should
put in the key
and get started
and start driving
your app to Android Auto.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Let's hit
that accelerator, and off we go.
ANDREW BRENNER: Absolutely.
We use all the puns we can.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Exactly.
ANDREW BRENNER: All right.
You want to get going?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Sounds good to me.
ANDREW BRENNER: All right.
Sounds good.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So we've
gotten our coffee now.
Thanks for joining me
for coffee today, Andrew.
And we've see all
these great things
that developers can do it within
the car using Android Auto.
But how can a
developer get started?
How can they just
really get building
these kind of really cool
apps that you've shown today?
ANDREW BRENNER: If
you're a developer,
you can go to
developer.android.com today
and download our STK for Auto.
And the documentation
will help you
to develop awesome,
great car apps.
And we're really looking
forward to seeing
what you come up with.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thanks for
spending some time with us
today, and thanks for
sharing a coffee with me.
And for everybody
else who's watching,
we're going to be doing
lots more episodes like this
of "Coffee with a Googler."
If there's any Googlers you'd
like to talk to, contact us
on our G+ page, and we'd
love to put them in front
of the camera.
Thanks again, and happy coffee.